[Music]
Warners other Studios in Hollywood it's
the Conan audience II Awards celebrating
excellence in the sitting and looking
arts here now is your host Brian
I believe I get to host this show that's
right it's the audience the awards this
is a word show that recognizes the
audience for a night this important I
think I need to dress the part Bruce if
you don't mind I should market this we
would make a fortune guys would love it
all right ladies and gentleman here it
is the coveted audience II statue you
grew up wishing one day you could have
fun don't know if that's a man or a
woman I don't think it really matters at
this point it's a beautiful it took 11
minutes to make this award it's precious
let's get right to it our first audience
II award is for the best impression of a
celebrity and the audience e goes to the
person in seat 5d for their impression
of President Dwight D Eisenhower this is
exciting yes
[Applause]
you honor us with your presence sir
for looking like that guy the next
audience II also for a best impression
of a celebrity the audience he goes to
the person in seat 16 II for their
impression of Rick Moranis that's right
[Music]
Oh oh my god all right and finally
finally one more audience the award for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the audience member
who most clearly looks like tennis star
Andy Roddick let's see if he's here
there he is
[Music]
he gets that all the time alright our
next award goes to the person in seat 4s
it's the award for the audience member
who is building a woman in his bedroom
now this is
[Music]
I tried it didn't I tried to build one
of those the next audience II goes to
the person in seat 15m it's the award
for the audience member who thought they
were coming to a real estate seminar I
think it's a couple of them
[Music]
our last audience e goes to the audience
member who can join me on stage the
fastest right now and the winner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you